pleasant person to talk to you're very
smart you're a delightful delightful
chap just say that and then people don't
say chap enough in my onion and I I'm
gonna start saying it more often but you
I think there's people sometimes get
this inaccurate impression of you yeah
that maybe you're kind of unhappy or
brooding is you you find that people
think that about you
some sometimes I mean look at your face
right now see to me right now I'm I'm
happy to be here I'm excited that I'm on
Conan and but then I look at the monitor
up there and I look pissed you do you do
I mean if I didn't know any better I
would say right now that you're very
unhappy I'm furious you're furious and
anyone who's watching this with the
sound off anywhere in the United States
thinks that I'm talking to someone who
hates me hates Andy Oh
hates the entire crowd I'm looking I'm
looking right there and I want to murder
Andy yeah I want to slit his throat yeah
and then take his head off
yeah but in actuality I'm thrilled so
the problem is I I would actually once
with I was with a friend and we ran into
a woman I hadn't seen in a while and and
I said hello we had a quick interaction
and moved on and I remember my my friend
was like whoa like what's the story what
what happened there holy holy cow I was
like what no that's so-and-so and she's
great and he was like you just spoke to
her like she was your worst enemy and so
ever since then I've I've I've wondered
why that is but it's something I am
trying to work on as is not trying to
not trying to appear so angry all the
time yes can you can you make yourself
smile a little bit no that's impossible
I think it has something to do with that
the with it's got to be connected to
some sort of low self-esteem as you I
don't think so I think it's your facial
but you have very you know you've got
these strong eyebrows that look kind of
intense
maybe that's it's like light maybe I
need to carry
around a light just underneath me at all
times so you can see the rest of my well
then people would think you were Jesus
that's true which I wouldn't mind right
that would have its advantages sure I
have the same issue where people are
used to seeing me on TV I'm so I'm I'm
an upbeat ya kind of guy like this yeah
when I walk around if I'm neutral
yeah neutral just looks like this yeah
yes and people come up to me and say
what's wrong
yes are you okay Conan yeah because and
it's me just with a perfect line across
my mouth yeah and I think why don't I
have the right to just be just this is
not this is a normal setting for most
humans that is exactly right I think
that's that's yes exactly I I would
never ever approach you if that's what
you saw this face would you come to me
would you say hello you you look like a
statue in front of a government building
[Laughter]
the sad comment on our government
compliments we have I love your shoes by
the way fantastic I talked to you about
them backstage and I just love them I
can't pull that off but your dad they're
not mine you know people don't show them
the people don't know this about
celebrities the clothes that they wear
aren't theirs
no they belong to other people and
they're put on you as if you're a child
that's right and then when you're done
with this segment they take them away
from you I have to there are two people
backstage and they're dressed like like
1983 parents and they're their Giants
too so they they feel like they're
bigger than me and I go back there and I
start talking like a little boy and they
take my clothes off and they bring me to
the bathroom and then they dress me Wow
and this is my fetish as well not go to
school
always fantasize about we have a clip
from big little lies yeah I think this
is a scene where you are with the lovely
Reese Witherspoon yes I am and you two I
think are having some difficulties with
your marriage okay
no and I'm not director asking you to do
a see okay we've got Reese here you're
gonna do she's backstage let's do it so
so this is young okay you know you tell
me why am I telling you what the clip is
all right this is what I do before I act
I it's like it's you know it's like it's
like an Olympic sport it really you want
to talk about acting no I really don't
okay I've seen I've seen shows where
they talk about aggregate awful it's
awful terrible I mean you've had a few
people on here talking about acting I'm
sure it's Darrell how dare you criticize
I'm criticizing that nevermind yeah
now I mean now I will look at this ad
Thanks
we have a clipper from big little lives
you and Reese Witherspoon not getting
along let's take a look okay then what
are you trying to say to me please just
tell me I have no idea on our first date
it was like you were interviewing me not
so much for the soulmate position or
lover but rather father the stable
provider a Miguel was ripped apart and
you were determined to fix that to not
make the mistake of going down the lust
path again you had a certain criteria
and I checked all the boxes so you made
the sound of practical choice it's not
something I couldn't make peace with I
did but then you got unsettled you
decided to make impractical choices
great big little lies airs Sundays at
9:00 on HBO I got to get the word out on
that show you Adam Scott congratulations
[Applause]